you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
a renewables record as more wind hydro
and solar power is installed around the
world than ever before but there's a
warning it's still nowhere near enough
why meat and dairy production could be
undermining key climate and
deforestation goals made at the cot 26
summit
and the irreplaceable trees damaged in
storm arwen as the national trust says
gardens and landscapes could take
decades to restore
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now a record number of solar panels wind
turbines and other forms of renewable
power have been installed around the
world this year according to the
international energy agency it found
that capacity from renewable energy is
now predicted to exceed that of both
fossil fuels and nuclear by just 2026.
so far in 2021 290 gigawatts of
renewables have been commissioned around
the world now to put that into context
one gigawatt of power would power 10
million light bulbs the amount of
capacity installed this year is 3 more
than 2020 which was itself a record year
for renewable growth now according to
the iea 95
of the increase in global energy
generation over the next five years will
come from renewables rather than fossil
fuels or nuclear power
more than half of that will come from
solar power nearly 30 percent will come
from wind power and the remainder will
be from other renewable sources mainly
hydroelectric which uses the power of
water in motion to generate electricity
well renewables capacity is growing all
over the world but it's exploding in
china where they are expected to reach
1200 gigawatts by
2026 now that's four years ahead of
their 2030 budget
and india is set to double its capacity
setting it well on the way to a target
of 50 of electricity to come from
renewable sources by the end of the
decade
well here in the uk the aim is for 100
of the country's electricity to come
from renewables by 2035. and if we look
at our real-time power mix in great
britain right now we can see that 38 of
electricity
is coming from gas around 2 from coal 36
from renewables
6 from biomass and 10
is coming from nuclear
but the international energy agency says
the growth rate of renewable capacity
must double if the world is to meet its
target of net zero emissions by 2050 as
our business correspondent helen smith
explains so this is a really detailed
report from the international energy
agency essentially having a really good
look at the renewables market how's it
performing what value's been added is it
enough and on the surface of it it's
pretty good news the report says we're
really set to massively accelerate the
amount of renewable energy that we have
globally up to the year 2026 in fact 95
of new energy new power sources in that
time will be renewables and as you said
in your introduction there by that date
the renewable sector energy added will
be the equivalent of the entire fossil
fuel energy capacity that we currently
have at the moment so that's really good
news it pointed as well to the speed in
which these things are being added it
will really speed up in the next five to
six years compared to what it has been
doing so that's good news
why is it doing so well well the report
pointed to uh positive uh support from
governments commitments made at cop and
other things as well but crucially as
well it's as much about private sector
investment and private sector incentives
and there really are incentives for the
private sector to invest in renewable
energies it can really see that there is
money to be made
in this sector in the years to come
is it enough well sadly as with so many
things when it comes to climate change
the report says no at the moment it's
not uh in order to reach the targets uh
that we should be reaching uh wind and
solar capacity would need to double
again in the next six years and things
like bioenergy as well would need to
quadruple again in order to reach those
targets so it's not enough but the
report really points to the fact that if
there could be a little bit more support
for the private sector then many many
more hundreds of billions of dollars of
investment could be unlocked things like
uh more uh support in kind of
integrating into the national grid
things like that would really help so
lots still to do but good news for a
burgeoning sector that will clearly help
in the flight against climate change
let's take a look announce on the day's
other climate news and northern ireland
experienced its warmest autumn on record
this year over september october and
november the temperature in the country
averaged 10.9 degrees celsius the
unusually warm autumn followed the
nation's third warmest summer on record
during which a national record of 31.3
degrees celsius was set
more than a quarter of uk bird species
are now considered seriously threatened
green finch's swifts and the buick swan
has been added to the red list on the
birds of conservation concern report
overall 70 species are in severe decline
or at risk of extinction according to
the new assessment from a coalition of
government wildlife bodies and bird
charities
the business and energy secretary quasi
quattang has told mps that weather
events like storm arwin could become
more frequent in the uk due to climate
change it comes as thousands of homes
are still without electricity five days
after the storm hit northern england and
scotland
and that warning comes as the national
trust says storm irwin has caused severe
damage to some of the uk's most precious
trees as the world famous bodnant garden
in north wales more than 50 trees were
uprooted including a 51 metre coast
redwood the full extent of the damage is
still being assessed but the restoration
is likely to cost more than three
million pounds
and last year captain sir tom moore
raised nearly 40 million pounds for the
nhs by walking 100 laps of his garden
now an area of ancient woodland near his
childhood home in west yorkshire will be
renamed captain tom's memorial wood in
honour of his efforts three thousand new
hedgerow trees will also be planted on
the 17 acres of land at home house wood
now we farm animals for food risks how
we farm animals for food risks
undermining key climate and
deforestation goals set out at the cop26
summit a network of food industry
investors has warned only 18 of global
meat fish and dairy producers are on
track to achieve even a partial
reduction in their methane emissions so
let's look back to cop26 which began
just a month ago where more than 100
countries signed the global methane
pledge agreeing to cut emissions of the
greenhouse gas by 30 percent now the un
food agency says livestock accounts for
44
of man-made methane emissions yet
according to a report by the fair
initiative less than a fifth of the
world's biggest livestock producers
currently measure even some of their
emissions
now the report also found that 93 of
meat and dairy farmers who source soy
for animal feed from areas at high risk
of deforestation
do not have a policy to mitigate the
practice
well joining me now is arty ramachandran
who's director of research and
engagements at the fair initiative so
welcome to you
so tell us what more can be done then
what can animal agriculture do to reduce
their methane emissions short of stop
farming
cattle well i mean that is part of it
but i mean let's go back to some of the
stats that you pointed out anna which is
that uh most of these companies are yet
to start tracking uh emissions methane
emissions um as you've pointed out less
than a fifth of these companies are
actually tracking methane emissions and
even these are partial methane emissions
and let's be very clear without us
reducing methane emissions on an annual
basis we are not going to meet the you
know keep temperature rise to to under
1.5 c um that's simply not going to uh
sort of happen uh you know looking at
some of the pathways that the ipcc has
put forth so we absolutely need for
companies to be taking this very
seriously what is it up to companies
sorry to interrupt sorry to interrupt i
was just going to mention the fact that
as we said in our introduction it was
over 100 world leaders who signed this
methane emissions pledge at cop26 but is
it down to governments then who've
signed up to this to take the lead on
this rather than companies
well i'd say it's both isn't it i mean
we all have to be doing our jobs as part
of the body politic i mean certainly
regulators and policy makers need to be
making the right or sending the right
signals the right incentives for these
companies to make the changes necessary
as do the company leadership i mean they
have to recognize that this is a risk to
their business this growing climate
transition risk is going to increase
costs of doing business for these
companies it's going to also sort of
have a range of physical risk and
repercussions for them as temperature
temperatures increase it's going to uh
start you know sort of increasing feed
volatility it's going to start reducing
the productivity of their animals so
it's something that they really
absolutely have to take much more
seriously and so we all and as consumers
of course we have to make the right
choices uh so i think it's it's uh you
know it's a confluence of uh measures
that that many many actors have to take
well that's interesting you talk about
making the right choices what role do
you think that individuals can play and
how important is transparency
when individuals decide to make their
choices
well i mean the fact is that consumers
if if there is a responsibility for
consumers it is to ask more questions as
and as many consumers already are right
and so we're seeing that you know
consumers want to know what's on their
plate they want to know how uh some of
their food was made and what the sort of
climate impacts or environmental impacts
um was was involved in making that food
um and i mean sorry but to come back to
the question of individuals i mean we
have investors too asking very similar
questions they're asking questions on
exactly what are we financing because if
we're financing companies that have
you know large-scale deforestation and
full of forest loss in their supply
chains that means we're financing
companies that are vulnerable to a
damaged brands they're financing
companies that are exacerbating climate
risks which then could sort of in turn
come back and reduce the productivity of
these companies themselves so that's
something that that investors are
beginning to take much more seriously
now
artie ramachandran very interesting to
talk to you thanks very much indeed
thank you
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'm going to be joined by mikhail
nachmany from climate policy radar and
senior lecturer in climate law at
edinburgh university navaraj gali and
we're going to be discussing if the
world is moving to renewable energy fast
enough and whether we all need to go
vegan to save the planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm lisa dowd and i'm skye's midlands
correspondent we can reveal that the
driver who hit harry dunn is 42 year old
and sir cool ass just met the president
and we never thought we'd get this far
this is what they're up against is back
breaking work
[Music]
water levels are dropping but no one
knows what impact further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary in this community i'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid
change seems tantalisingly close in this
corner of the uk
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
the morning will be mainly fine but
there'll be wintry showers in the
southwest for a time and near northern
and eastern coasts it'll be cold for
most mild in the far west
showers in the east will become
increasingly confined to norfolk through
the afternoon most places will then be
fine into the evening but ireland
northern ireland and western scotland
will see some rain and hill snow later
clean north atlantic air means air
pollution levels will remain low
measuring just two or three on the air
quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with dr
mikhail nachmany founder and ceo of
climate policy radar and navaraj gali a
senior lecturer in climate law at the
university of edinburgh so a very good
evening to both of you nice to see you
both
so first of all two reports out today
show there's been a huge expansion in
renewable energy capacity across the
world but there's also warning that it's
not enough to reach global net zero
targets by the middle of the century and
that fresh first of all i just want to
point out what the iea have said about
this they say that
this year's record renewable electricity
additions are another sign that a new
global energy economy is emerging would
you agree it's really good news isn't it
yeah it is good news i mean it's uh the
extension of a trend which we've been
seeing for actually for quite a long
time
and especially after uh in the last
couple of years it's been very difficult
to get financing for new
uh fossil fuel projects which
is a climactically very positive step so
you know this is part of the trajectory
which we've been mapping the the
question is is the rate of change
sufficiently fast um and i think
most views would be that no it isn't but
the
there are reasons to be optimistic that
uh you know the rate of change will it
will increase uh to the appropriate
levels well yes and we'll come back to
that but mika what do you make of this
do you think it shows that the world is
taking climate change seriously
i think those answers are never binary
and uh we always have to ask how can we
do more and faster and how can we
accelerate the rate of the transition
while waking it while making it
equitable and sustainable uh worth it
for investors worth it for private
companies worth it for individuals so we
can all benefit from those changes now
the point here is that this is a
virtuous circle potentially between
policy making and between um the private
sector policy making has
sent positive signals as the ia notes in
its report that have facilitated this
transition
continuing those um uh signals is what
enables faster deployment of renewables
but also we need to remember the
complete the competing and the
completing side of this which is fossil
fuels
the more we legislate and regulate
fossil fuel consumption exploration and
so on
the more that we are more uh the more
that we can advance renewables and that
is a really important thing to to do
those things to in tandem now the policy
measures that will advance renewable
energy and drive down the cost of those
will enable us to do more
to have even more ambitious policy
measures in place
bringing
forward for example
india's uh
ndc target which is currently a net zero
by 2070 and currently facilitated by the
current prices of renewables bring those
down with faster deployment globally and
we'll be able to bring that um even
faster well yes another do you agree
with that because as you were hinting
the the iea is saying at the moment the
rate of increase is not fast enough to
hit those net zero targets so
how much is this down to governments do
you think and how much will it be down
to market forces
well market forces are working uh very
conveniently for a lot of renewables uh
so
in large parts of the world practically
everywhere uh renewables are cost
competitive or undercutting the price of
new uh fossil fuels which is why we're
seeing the balance of uh new capacity
that you described earlier
for the purposes of governments though
what we're seeing is that whilst a lot
of progress is being made in a lot of
places there is still really strong
financial pipeline for
new fossil fuel investments
through export credit agencies through
the belt and road initiative in china so
you know there's there's there's there
are a number of different stories here
there's the you know open
market liberal um world and then you
know there's the larger part of the
world frankly in which this isn't uh the
case so you know if you look along the
belton road you'll see
huge uh the pipeline of uh coal-fired
power plants the uh transmission of
fossil fuels is still in a relatively
healthy place and that is just not at
all consistent with a one and a half
degree or even a two and a two degree
world michael very briefly um there was
an agreement at cop as well among some
countries to stop in in investing in
overseas fossil fuel plants i mean
that's progress as well isn't it
uh but we need to remember that not
invest not investing in coal for example
is important but building infrastructure
that is very carbon intensive um such as
the belt and road initiative is
something that will lock us into many
years
of uh
of carbon intensive uh usage of that
infrastructure and those things are
really important to remember so like
navarrete said we really needed to
make those policy steps now
both on the fossil fuels and on the
renewables and those work in tandem the
sooner that fossil fuels uh will be
um
not uh competitive and some of them
already aren't with renewable energy the
easier will be to phase those out okay
let's move on to our next topic now
shall we and a new report today has
claimed that cows are the new coal so as
we heard earlier the fair global
investor coalition are calling for far
more to be done to address emissions
from the agricultural sector so is it
time we all went vegan to help address
climate change and navrah let me just
quote from this commission fair they say
that the emissions from agriculture are
on a level with the greenhouse gases
emitted by the eu us and japan combined
so what's your take on this is it
possible to farm animals without harming
the planet
um i'm surrounded actually where i live
i'm surrounded by fields which are full
of sheep and cows so i spend a lot of my
time dodging them but um
there are all sorts of innovations which
um animal scientists are uh engaging
with on feedstocks for uh cattle cattle
and but the the fundamental issue i
think is really around what is happening
on mass scale farming uh in particular
in places like brazil where we're not
only consider where the uh emissions
associated with uh beef in particular
are not just the ways in which cows emit
gases from both ends uh but but
especially from the deforestation which
is associated with that style of uh
raising cattle and
that is a very very tough nut to crack i
mean it's you know what again talking
about one of those hard to regulate
jurisdictions of bolsonaro's brazil uh
so
you know engaging in that sort of
context is much much harder i think and
equally critical
food and land use are really you know
the two of the hardest to abate sectors
electricity which is where we started
this conversation is where we've made
massive strides if you as you've just
indicated but food and land use are
really much much harder and we've
scarcely started working on working in
that space
well that's right doesn't it michael and
the the decision about whether to go
vegan is a very personal one people want
choice don't they they and and telling
people what they should eat is is going
to be very very tough no people want to
be able to be individuals and with
something as basic as diet they want to
choose their own food
you're absolutely right and i think if
we think about um you know you put out
the word vegan out there and this is
very emotional and you put out anything
that relates to food and we're already
in a culture war and that is important
to acknowledge and it's important for us
to do that and bring everyone along with
us
and bring that bring everyone along with
us is enable a transition to lower
carbon um
lives and livelihoods that will enable
us to transition to net zero while not
um um okay
interviewing in everybody's diet but
very quickly here's the story right if
renewables replace uh replace fossil
fuels we already have alternatives to
meet we have a lower uh carbon
electricity sorry land based and lab
grown and we really need to think about
those in the same terms that we think
about renewables okay lovely sorry to
cut you off we're out of time but you
made your point very well there mikhail
nakhmani and navraj gali thanks both
very much indeed
so that's it for me for tonight do stay
tuned for sky news tonight we've got a
panel of experts who's going to be
answering your questions about the new
omicron variant of kovid 19.
[Music]